احنا موجودين في هالبلاد موجودين وعايشين
فيها وين اروح وين اروح
بدهم يطلعونا وين بدنا نروح
انولدنا هان وعشنا هان وبنشطل هان
دوافعوا انتقاميه وعقاب جماعي لتحقيق
مكاسب سياسيه على حساب الحقوق الاساسيه
للمدنيين هكذا يصف الفلسطينيون اصدار
تعليمات لهدم 14 منشاه ومنزلا للفلسطينيين
والتي تم تنفيذ سبع منها في حي الطور
وسلوان وجبل المكبر ومناطق اخرى تعتبر
حساسه واستراتيجيه في القدس
انا دارك فيها رخصه وجاهدها
ظهر انا بدي اهدها
انا جاي اه مشكل في حكومه اسرائيل ما في
عليه
السلطات الاسرائيليه بهدم منشات لانها
بدون ترخيص لكنه منشاه المقدسي اكرم عميره
تم هدمها على الرغم من حصوله على رخصه
بناء من بلديه القدس التابعه لا
ودفعه رسوم الرخصه باهظه الثمن الا ان
وزاره الداخليه اصدرت قرارا بهدمها حسب
القانون احنا حملنا حالنا ورحنا حسب
القانون وجبنا اللي هو الرخصه
الترخيص حسب القانون
وانا ماشي ولما بنيت حسب القانون اجوا
فحصوني
على احياء كامله مهدده بالهدم والاخلاء
مثل حي بطن الهوى في سلوان جنوب المسجد
الاقصى في القدس المهدد بالهدم لاستبداله
بحدائق ثوراتيه لصالح المستوطنين
هنا في قريه صور باهر في القدس تهدم
القوات الاسرائيليه منشاه لفلسطين قيد
الانشاء بعد اوامر وزير الامن القومي
المتشدد اعتمر بني كبير بهدم 14 منزلا
للفلسطينيين في القدس على الرغم من
المحاولات العربيه والامريكيه بالتهدئه
من القدس العربي